if you thought Neos alpha demo was a bit
too challenging or maybe a little unfair
it sounds like the developers were
listening it's been a couple weeks since
the alpha demo period ended and now
developer team ninja has detailed what
it'll change for the final game the
changes are based on feedback it
received from an online survey and
includes improved exploration elements
the removal of weapon and armor
durability and a revamped stamina system
other changes will consist of improved
player and camera behavior while logged
on to an enemy and upgraded graphical
performance the full game will also
implement a training stage however the
exact details of all these changes are
still unclear additionally if you need
to free up some space on your hard drive
Team Ninja has said it's safe to delete
the game if you completed the demo
you'll still get the mark of the
Conqueror reward once the full game
launches Team Ninja also shared some
visuals that showed how different
regions reacted to the demo
interestingly the Japanese developed
game has received more positive feedback
from the Americas in Europe than Asia
for example difficulty in game balance
is marked as very good by thirty-seven
percent of respondents and goodbye
thirty five percent while Asia responded
with only eleven percent and twenty-two
percent respectively Yeoh releases for
the ps4 this year for a full list of the
changes check out the article on
gamespot com